maintenant faut soit bill jo
tout bon choix
jean françois bizot ça fait du bien je
me paye non jean-françois ouais ça fait
du bien parce que en fait il faut savoir
que le premier concert en france de
double page
c'était une soirée de hec et alors
c'était une époque où des soins des
chaussées t'avais les mecs en smoking
tutelle et un peu pressés des appareils
et une chemise blanche
1 et puis les filles en robes longues et
puis deux mecs qui étaient en bas d'un
pilier en béton un site jours c'est vrai
on a un pied en béton ou jouer les deux
épines
paris les trois câbles un ampli de
fortune et joueurs bal empire mais tout
ça me fait assez strictement personne
c'est direct légion méfiant shocking et
les mecs en robe longue
ouais oui mais non il comprend les voir
un psy on la dit de plus en plus adjoint
chez scott en vieillissant jean françois
bizot jean françois bizot vous êtes
journalistes patrons de presse fondateur
d'actuels de nova de radio nova
vous êtes écrivain il ya les déclassés
qui ressort en ce moment
oui
et puis les années blanches donc tous
les deux chez grasset voilà et vous
publiez actuellement un livre qui
s'appelle un moment de faiblesse
alors serait dû s'appeler même pas mal
et pourtant ça fait mal puisque jean
françois bizot vous racontez votre
cancer un cancer de la vessie
je vous dit je sais pas si c'est mon
plus grand reportage
mais c'est mon plus long reportage bah
oui puisqu'il est pas finie et que en
fait on apprend dans cette aventure
on apprend une patience dont on ne peut
pas vous prévenir
on peux pas vous dire il va falloir être
patient parce que c'est décourageant
donc on vous dit oued en 3 - tu vas voir
il ya prés offert aux battues 3 mois de
plus car pour te tiens si on en a
rajouté une couche on va te greffe était
proposée dur ça va être intéressant
il s'agit d'ailleurs vous dites
d'ailleurs le patient est impatient par
définition
alors on parle de reportages moi je
crois que c'est surtout de la
littérature je vais dire le le début du
camp j'ai barbouillé des dizaines de
céramique blanche du g2 mon pinceau
rupestres carmin vermillon fuchsia rose
pivoine rouge brun chaque pigments
afficher une consistance appartenant à
une peinture différentes
j'ai jamais le même rouge vous dit le
rouge c'est rothko moi je comparerais le
bouquin au tableau de munch qui
s'appelle le cri ou un tableau de bacon
tu vois c'est c'est comme ça c'est un
peu comme ça ce bouquin on m'a dit ben
il est tout nu sans être à poil
1 donc c'est une transaction avec les
puissants d'être un poil donc tu peux de
publier un parce que en fait parce qu'en
fait le con bascule du jour au lendemain
dans une autre société c'était bien
vous qui connaissez le clubbing où d'un
seul coup on a le vip pass gold de la
nouvelle société qui s'appelle le cancer
club avant c'est une maladie qu'on
pourrait nommer
si vous vouliez je pourrais vous la mi
mai c'est à dire c'est une manie comme
ça hein
et ça c'est de trois heures par jour
pendant un certain temps
c'est une maladie comme ça après les
injections de corticoïdes ouais c'est
une maladie comme ça ouais quand on a
mal ouais et ça fait mal alors on les
trempe on fait ça on a pas mal
d'ailleurs
alors on pas au début si la découverte
du mal justement des taches de sang sur
des toilettes verte
ça se passe en inde alors il ya deux
solutions soit c'est la bilharziose qui
est une maladie qu'on peut choper dans
les pays exotiques c'est des petites
amies soit ça qui choisit le cancer est
en fait malheureusement le diagnostic
c'est le cancer vous revenez à paris
vous passer sur le billard le
chirurgiens retirent dites-vous une
tumeur de la taille d'un d'un quart d'un
paquet de dany l'a300 une balle de tact
pour un traitement que vous 600 milles
vannes
je vous l'avait attrapée en finir ce
faire vous avez attrapé en fumant ben je
pense que c'est un cancer qui présente
l'inconvénient de ne pas être déclarés
sur le paquet club de copenhague à la
veille par là dessus c'est pas des
poumons c'est la vessie oui ah bah oui
c'est qu'on n'y pense pas alors
évidemment le chirurgien vous au père et
puis après vous dis moi j'ai tout raclée
1 j'ai enlevé le plus possible mais je
suis pas assis là il arrive que l'herbe
repousse et donc c'est la signaux
monsieur bah c'est pas terrible
tomic la chimio ouais c'est une guerre
et là c'est le début
du voyage dans le monde de la douleur
puisque peas et devient un calvaire à ce
moment là les vire oui ça peut dire
qu'il vit un calvaire c'est chiant voilà
les limaces géantes c'est quoi les
images et les humains les limaces jantes
c'est un truc qui se passe quand on a
été opéré de cette partie du corps où
ils appellent ça des c'est ainsi que
très souvent c'est des chutes des
scarlets et en fait c'est quand même
pour les mecs comme nous un truc assez
curieux observé quoi parce que en fait
on se retrouve là c'est bouché donc un
plaisir de douleur et puis il faut
expulser un truc elle qui passe par un
conduit qui n'a pas été prévue demain à
la bonne taille tuto est là tu vois tu
lâches un petit tuyau là comme ça et
puis pouf
ils sont une menace un immense mais ce
weed on va on va dire les choses c'est
super drôle en fait dans les hôpitaux
les mecs se marre ils l'ont lu à la
cantine j'avais déjà lu une est restée
tout utilisent ce serait difficile avec
ce passé une sale journée
il sort un truc qui fait très mal voilà
ça fait mal à chaque fois et puis en
avoir 50 cars et l'habitant charpy il
faut dire là faut dire les choses
avaient une sonde dans le canal de
l'urètre et alors il ya une règle d'or
c'est gore il ya une scène dans votre
bouquin toute l'europe
terrible c'est un soir vous mourrez née
un soir où les vous hurlez alors les
médecins viennent les infirmières bien
ils voulaient sur les pans des heures
vous dites je vote tanaisie à ce moment
là je vous dis pas ce que je ferais un
chiotte
ouais mais je prononcer le nom d'un
homme politique menu
puis pour talons veulent membres dont ce
[ __ ] 1
c'était ça m'aidait votre façon de vous
défouler à saluer
d'ailleurs je découverte finalement que
d'un des meilleurs combats contre la
douleur
c'est de manifester en gros donc c'est
de prendre le nom du médecin qui tenta
par exemple se pointent vers vous avec
un tuyau comme ça pour vous mettre un
truc tout petit mois je suis je pas été
doté par la nature et donc il a allégué
1 et bien il faut manifester parce quand
on manifeste saint mobilise le cerveau
donc prendre un bain de sang devenu
tombe du bon et on fait du bon et de
file du front ça nos bombes et deux
filles cède jury quatre fois le
comprendre ouais ils voulaient sur les
comme ça pendant tout l'été mais non ils
ne savent rien
non à un moment ils s'aperçoivent que la
sonde est trop gonflé mais ils peuvent
rien il s'alimente situation ils sont
trois pour 25 personnes
ça va pas ce [ __ ] ils sont trois pour
25 personnes et chaque chambre
chaque endroit c'est 10 à 15 minutes de
soins ouais donc tu sonnes et il faut
que j'aie le temps d'arriver et puis
arriva pire que toi oui toi t'as juste
mal mais les autos mois pour leur change
à 1,1002 faire
mais voilà alors évidemment là vous vous
donner des détails qui sont
malheureusement vrai quoi c'est à dire
qu'à ce moment là tu as le prépuce
extrêmement bon flée le gland marbré et
alors il ya un mélange comme ça sous le
prépuce de 2,2 crème un des
opportunistes et des maladies
opportunistes faisait des champignons
par exemple et et vous dites je n'avais
jamais vécu en tête à tête
un spectacle personnel aussi navrant
c'est à dire que vous êtes navré en fait
de voir l'état de votre sexe ça c'est
vrai que depuis l'arrêt parce que je
peux pas le montrer en plus donc
déjà ça c'est navrant vont servir
donc ça c'est navrant je me demande ce
que c'est après donc jeanmaire dans quoi
je vous rassure
et puis vous dit jean françois labbé est
impossible dit sans fard écroulé
alexandre y perdit son pouvoir shopper
des quenouilles ouais vous n'avez plus
droit l'alcool maintenant bon je vais
rien empêché way la drogue non moyen
d'empêcher un partie du deal
wen en livre d'ailleurs j'assume et
j'assume très très fortement le cannabis
thérapeutique que je l'avais quittée
pendant dix ans oui on vous dit le
cannabis est devenue un tic donc
j'arrête et puis vous reprenez pour des
raisons thérapeutiques
oui je peux dire pourquoi un l'ayant
vécu ça m'a beaucoup surpris j'y croyais
pas mais j'y croyais pas c'était un peu
de tout niveau et j'ai fait ce choix est
en fait un plat ni c'est les sautes
d'humeur
les produits soient extrêmement violent
et
sarr construisait l'appétit par contre
étrangement dans toutes les drogues
qu'on va faire prendre parce que
finalement dans cette magie on ne sait
prendre toutes les drogues possibles
imaginables qui ont que d'aucunes la
même façon de plaisir si je suis en vie
est-ce qu'il fallait publier ce bouquin
on m'a dit oui on m'a dit oui on m'a dit
ça donne la pêche
ouais alors j'ai fait un bon et puis
ça fait bizarre parce que c'est je
ressens ce truc comme un livre écrit par
un procédé qui n'est pas - et comment ça
va se passer maintenant
la suite des événements terminés ou
terminés c'est tous les jours et encore
la chimio à venir la chimio c'est que
ces cas chignon
c'est variable pour les gens il ya dans
la chimio il ya il ya le truc qui est
chiant c'est de l'imprévisibilité de du
moment on va être annulé
on est un ide et tout d'un coup on n'est
plus rien ouais on tient un journal à la
main la donne ça tourne à choisir un
journal très facile à lire jean
libération bon un truc pas prise de tête
du tout cas bon on tient là puis tombe
et on dit merde il est tombé non peut
rien faire donc ça c'est cheminots mais
le le truc le plus marrant mais dans les
têtes marrant parce que je pense que
face à humain c'est quand même été cloué
comme ça tu vois un genre jésus christ
enfin ton tour au fait que jouer parce
que on te prends ton sens de la la on le
fait circuler pour préparer des
nouvelles cellules de toi même pour
toutes au clown et parce que c'est
après-demain hyper moderne qui va très
bien et tout un tas d'autres trucs comme
ça l'an 7 heures peut pas bouger du tout
c'est chiant mais qu'est-ce qui fait
chier quand on peut pas bouger
bien joué voilà un vrai mec qui connaît
la vie et alors tu peux pas de gratter
évidemment tu t'aperçois ce moment là
pendant sept heures du nombre de fois où
tu as envie de te gratter
invraisemblable fugace à lui tout et tu
cries venir gratter non et alors là il
se passe un truc absolument terrible
c'est que les autres ne savent pas te
gratter ça peut être une fille tu te dis
ça va donner quoi il s'était relevé
elle prétend avoir gardé choisi alcatel
montant donné que tu sens plus rien
pendant sa série
nadine vous avez connu ce genre de
maladie j'imagine nom et avec mon mari
et notre naïve c'est pourquoi il n'avait
pas de cancer il avait dû tous les
problèmes que vous avez décrit en partie
il n'avait pas de cancer mais il a fait
de l'emphysème ski team à être ainsi
très très difficile à gérer et mais
était d'un courage comme vous monsieur
extraordinaire âge sans public et puis
la lâcheté c'est dans les chiottes
jean françois bizot à novembre
et c'est grâce et mais la maison
jean-françois je voulais c'est les ou
couché merci en tous les cas d'avoir été
avec nous courage mon nom mais j'avais
un chef jack à 6
je suis redevenu un lâche et je peux
m'en aller
et maintenant